hey guys welcome back to the channel So
today we're going to be talking about
coordination Services which should
really wrap up this whole concept of
consensus and once we're done with this
video allow us to compare and contrast a
bunch of different database Technologies
and you know just really understand why
it is that they perform the way that
they perform I don't think the video
should be more than a couple minutes
long which you know if you ask me
personally is a pretty long time I don't
know my ex-girlfriend might not agree
but that is an argument for a different
day so let's go ahead and get into it
all right so like I mentioned today
we're going to be talking about
coordination services so there's not a
ton of technical content to cover in
this video the reasoning being that we
just did it in the last
two coordination services are basically
just thin layers that are built on top
of some distributed consensus algorithm
like raft in order to basically help us
with all of this configuration that we
need within our distributed backend so
what type of configuration could that be
well we have IP addresses for things
like our servers our databases our load
balancers our CDN anything along those L
are replication schema what database is
sending rights to which where are those
databases located who is the leader
currently all super important stuff and
then also something like a partitioning
breakdown what partitions are located on
which node what range of keys does that
include or what hash range of keys does
that include we have tons of
configuration that if we were to mess it
up via you know something that allowed
us to have right conflicts or race
conditions or just stale reads in
general then obviously viously the
basically correctness of our service
would be hugely jeopardized and this
would be way more you know kind of
damaging to our user base than
potentially one single lost comment so
kind of the the logic here is that even
though consensus is slow for things like
uh the configuration of our application
we're willing to make that trade-off
because it's extremely important to get
it right so the typical pattern that you
would use is you would put this
configuration in something like a
coordination service which again is just
a small key value store and then for
your actual application data you know
user Post history comments anything like
that you would use a different type of
database that itself may be relying on
the coordination service to be correct
so what are some examples of modern-day
coordination Services well the two that
you've probably heard of or at least may
sound familiar would be zookeeper or
etcd uh etcd or whatever it's pronounced
uh runs on raft zookeeper runs on its
own thing called Zab that's similar to
Raft but the point is they're using
distributed consensus so if there is any
technical content in this video it would
basically just be how reads work because
we've covered how wrs and leader
election work in consensus but how will
we actually read the data to make sure
that we're getting linearizable reads
because if I were to write a piece of
data and then not be able to read it
right after from some replica that would
be problematic that would make our
application prone to incorrectness and
cause problems down the line so like
I've mentioned multiple times now we
were built on top of some distributed
consensus layer and if you remember from
me drawing drawing this pretty much for
the last three or four videos that
basically means that we've got some sort
of leader and then a couple of follower
nodes and the follower nodes are not
necessarily completely up to date right
as you can see on the bottom here this
follower node is a bit behind so that is
a possibility in all of our distributed
consensus algorithms but there are still
ways to make sure that your reads are
linearizable what we don't want is a
client making a read right here so this
would be read one where we see xal 5 and
then that X equal 5 is it index one in
the log right because we go 0 1 2 and
what we don't want is for our client to
then go ahead and read from the node
that's behind over here and then see xal
3 because then our reads would not be
linearizable we can't be having that so
what can we do to avoid this situation
well we've got two easy options one we
can always just read from the leader
that's a super easy option however it
comes at the price of well if we're
always reading from the leader that
means that all writes and all reads are
going through the leader and that is
going to be slow another option is that
sometimes we can actually read from
different follower nodes the key thing
to note is that again we want those
reads to be linearizable so how can we
ensure that they actually are well at
least in Zookeeper there's some
functionality called the sync keyword so
again we have our client here let's
imagine that we read from the leader and
the re the leader is going to uh
basically report back that X is equal to
5 and that is an index one of the log
right like you're updated to index one
so what the leader or basically what the
client would then go ahead and do is
they say okay well I want a read from
this guy but I'm afraid that the data
there is stale and my read is not going
to be linearizable so I'm going to write
a keyword sync into the log and you can
see that goes over here at index 2 and
so sync is now going to get
propagated to these
nodes and so now since the client knows
that it's seen index one until it
actually reads back and now you know
eventually some more time passes and
this guy gets filled up to date blah
blah blah blah
blah and until it reads back and sees
sync at index
2 it knows that the data on the follower
node that it wants to read from is stale
once it does see sync then it can start
reading from that follower and you can
basically keep reading from that
follower until you either make another
right or until you BAS basically go
ahead and switch reading from a
different follower so yeah the fact that
you can do this means that we can have
greater read through put because once we
sync once we're going to start being
able to make linearizable reads from
that follower node and as a result of
being able to do that we take some of
the stress off of our leader so this
does allow us to have a little bit
greater of a read through put so let's
quickly do a conclusion for coordination
Services basically they're too slow to
be used for most of our application data
in a real massive service like Facebook
or Twitter or anything like that if
you're sending all the rights through a
single leader and basically that has to
effectively go through some sort of
two-phase commit we're running into some
serious performance problems that
probably are not going to be feasible
for the scale of our application at the
same time all of these apps have key
pieces of configuration which we
mentioned before are backend needs in
order to be able to run we need to know
the location of all of our nodes in our
cluster we need to be able to know what
data is stored on what partition things
like that and if we don't have that in a
reliable setting in a way that you know
we can access it and be sure that it's
correct then we're running into some
serious issues as well so typically the
solution would be to use something that
is a bit more scalable for application
data but then something like
coordination service for this
configuration and of course the reason
why we can rely on it is because it is
built on top of consensus algorithms
being able to read in a linearizable way
means that we can be sure that the data
that we're reading even though it could
technically be a little bit outdated
either a we could always read from the
leader or B at minimum our reads are
going to be linearizable so we're never
just going to like be jumping backwards
all of a sudden and seeing some previous
state that we weren't already aware of
and thinking it was more up to date than
our current state anyways guys I hope
that this helps understand what
coordination services are actually used
for only just a little bit of a pit stop
from you know continuing to talk about
databases and then in the next video we
will do just that yet again see you guys
then